hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolac.l
2-3.1.7 prevent non-privileged users
from executing privileged functions and
audit the execution of such functions
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you've
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero let's kick it so
here we get deeper into our controls on
making sure that our system is being
used in the way that we intend it to be
used the goal of cmmccontrol
ac.l2-3.1.7 prevents non-privileged
users from executing privileged
functions and audit the execution of
such functions is to Define what
functions are privileged versus
non-privileged making sure
non-privileged users cannot execute
those functions and then audit or make
sure that when those functions are
executed record of that is being kept so
it can be reviewed and the validity of
and authenticity can be verified to make
sure it's really one of your authorized
users and not some bad guy
uh now if I was an Assessor
and I was looking at how could I figure
out if you're actually complying with
this there's basically four major points
that I would be asking all right Point
number one is determinive privilege
functions are defined so somewhere did
we Define what is privilege privilege
functions are Def and if I was to give a
sample answer I would say privilege
functions are defined within each
individual system authorized users have
access to examples uh which may include
file system permissions right do you
have permission to access those
privileged folders like what contains
cui uh security groups OU's user
permission levels within different
systems all that kind of stuff right so
again lots and lots of different things
that we can actually uh use to determine
if privileged functions are defined
now assessment Point number two
determine if non-privileged users are
defined so are we defining who our
non-privileged users are non-profit
users could be defined so again sample
answer would be non-privile users are
defined via their membership role in
maybe an OU or a class of user like
administrators versus standard users and
user account type okay uh assessment
Point number three determine if
non-probled users are prevented from
executing privileged functions so how
are we actually preventing them from
being able to execute things they
shouldn't like installing new programs
non-probial users are prevented from
executing privileged functions via Group
Policy file system permissions and user
access capabilities within each system
right so again remember it's not just
the base operating system you got to
worry about in your domain you also got
to worry about things like your
accounting system and maybe your secure
engineering system whatever it may be
those are all places that you have to
take some consideration to
determine if the execution of privileged
functions is captured in Auto logs again
the final assessment Point uh and in
this one actually the answer is really
easy execution winds up being captured
in your seam solution so again the idea
is is that you have a security
information and event management system
it's capturing basically log files of
everything and you can determine if the
execution of privileged functions is
actually captured in there so pretty
cool have a seam system if you have no
idea what a steam system is here's the
good news and on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into the lap
like a single on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit
cmfccompliancecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now and if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance starts
rolling out and until the next time uh
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one foreign
[Music]